why is the white house trusting the
taliban startling new reports coming in
about the terror group carrying out mass
killings going house to house executing
american allies that president biden
left behind the white house says it
can't confirm those reports but is still
keeping the door open for cooperation
with the group to get stranded americans
and afghan allies out of the country
no one is saying from the federal
government no one the president
secretary of defense known from the
intelligence community that the taliban
are good actors right we are not saying
that we will judge and we want to make
clear this very clear we are going to
judge the taliban by their actions and
we will stay in close coordination with
the international community on any steps
that we take moving forward
joey what's disturbing about this none
of it is a surprise you're exactly right
and to interpret all their words up
until we got what they consider to be
everyone out of afghanistan
what they did they backed themselves
into a corner
they had no choice but to play nice with
taliban they had no choice but to ask
for their help if this report is correct
that we had a chance to secure the city
yeah that might have meant bringing in
ten thousand troops you're the president
of the united states you have three and
a half more years to end this war why do
you need to do it in the first eight
months of your presidency one if you
don't want to hand this war off to the
next person then end it correctly and
use your term to do it if you want to
give up some political collateral do it
saving american lives not holding to
some campaign promise that wasn't yours
to begin with it was the guy before you
who set this path in motion and you
didn't even follow his plan the taliban
it's not about can we we know we can't
trust the taliban and here's exactly why
we talked about the last block most of
their young fighters are coming from
madrasas and in pakistan they're
indoctrinated and they have a blood
thirst like no one else because they
haven't even seen war and the war might
not have even touched their lives so
this is a romanticized idealism of
radical islam in their head the taliban
does not have a choice to be this
outwardly benevolent ruling class
because they'll lose the thing that
makes them powerful which are those
bloodthirsty young men who think they
have to behead people and execute people
in public in order to fulfill their
righteous goal this is never going to be
a taliban 2.0 and that's why and they
talk to us like well we'll see if we
give them foreign aid you know what a
foreign aid looks like a j dam a guided
bomb right on their forehead that's what
for that's what that's the threat not
will we pay you it's will we kill you
and if you tell you it's over the
horizon we'll do it from afar that's
okay too
jessica even there was a headline that
came out it was a couple week or two ago
the taliban tell afghan women to stay at
home because the soldiers
are not trained to respect them
that was what the headline said say
there are limited gents left behind in
afghanistan who have been trained on how
to properly treat women um we were
talking about this last night uh on
kennedy just how good everyone else has
gotten at trolling at propaganda right
like these terror groups are fantastic
at it there was another scene the
taliban put out about uh how what a
wonderful partner china is and like
there's nothing that's going to upset
the us more than you're gone and i'm
turning to my best friend president xi
over here now
the veracity of those reports who knows
at this point any money that's coming in
and out of the country is obviously not
going to be something that you know the
world bank can look over um but we do
unfortunately have to work with people
we don't like all the time and and
that's a whole
range of you know even western
democracies or maybe we would disagree
with people do down to unfortunately
terror organizations that are running a
number of countries
this one just particularly hurts because
of our investment in this country for 20
years and the speed at which they took
over and i've rewatched a lot of the
footage about the 11 days and that
really does stick out as something that
it didn't even see president ghani knew
it was going to happen faster
necessarily than the u.s
intelligence apparatus but 11 days is in
an astonishingly quick
takeover and sorry no i was just gonna
go to sean it it particularly hurts and
i'm
speaking for joey haven't listened to
him very carefully the language not only
putting the haqqani network in charge of
security
in kabul
again
an individual who's wanted here the head
of the haqqani network wanted hearing
the fbi for being involved in the
killing including an america and there's
a bounty for him 5 million dollar bounty
with the language used by general
mckenzie of centcom referring to the
taliban is very helpful and pragmatic
and business-like and what hurts the
most sean is the fact that now we do
have to rely on this vicious hideous
terror organization because joe biden
left afghan allies partners and even
americans behind well to jessica's point
we do have to work with people that we
don't like but we didn't really have to
work with a taliban like this it was joe
biden's decisions to put us in the
situation and does the white house think
we're dumb and don't have videotapes or
youtube to go back and look at what they
said before i mean
the white house was saying the taliban
are our partners but now they're saying
they're not good people who was manning
the the gate to get into the kabul
airport when the 13 men and women died
from our military it was the taliban and
so they were trusting the taliban but
now they're saying they're not good
actors who do you think for 20 years was
attacking guys like joey jones well they
they knew the time they changed their
they changed their tone because they
knew it the whole time and now they have
ended their operation but the thing is
they think we're stupid they can say one
thing one week and something the other
week and think that we're going to
forget it's like well no listen let's
roll the tape and go how can you have
changing stories when the taliban hasn't
changed for probably more than 20 years
they're the same people violent horrible
um and uh and i agree we should be
dropping bombs
andy mccarthy prosecuted uh the
terrorists and the first world trade
center bombing the monuments plots and
he told me the taliban has never been
anything but the taliban and he
described the the nation state the
emirate that they set up and how that's
very different than anything that looks
like a representative government yeah
and general milley said he knows from
personal experience they are ruthless
now whether they change remains to be
seen i think we have a few skeptics here
uh among us today that's the line the
whole name rather they change remains to
be seen did north korea really think
otto warmbier was a spy
no but but that's that's the best
version of the taliban you're going to
get that's fine you don't need to to
change this for my feelings you need to
do it so my so my 12 year old son
doesn't fight him as an 18 year old
that's why i care well and you have
countries out there like denmark is the
first one to say we will not recognize
this as a legitimate government the
taliban so we're going to have to see of
course china is going to cozy up russia
we're going to have to see what others
do but what gets me is watching them
knowing they're going around executing
people that they are slaughtering people
they're killing people like a folks
musician because they don't believe in
music and that's sinful and terrible and
we have people here in the united states
saying women have it worse in the state
of texas than they do under the taliban
in afghanistan it is an outrageous
statement and if you think that i'm sure
there are a lot of people who buy you a
plane ticket to go hang out with the
taliban and see how you really feel
about that
i don't even have words to describe a
statement like that crazy
and as you know my mother would be very
upset if i cursed on live television but
she'd understand hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else